موجات الكراهية عبر 25
يومًا من حرائق الغابات المستعرة
لا تخطئ في حدوث تغير المناخ
ويقول العلماء إن البشر بحاجة
إلى اتخاذ إجراءات صارمة الآن لتجنب
التدمير البيئي الذي لا رجعة فيه في
وقت لاحق ولكننا نحن العالم الجماعي
لا يبدو أننا قادرون دائمًا على التحفيز
أنفسنا لنتحد معًا لفعل
أي شيء حيال ذلك ، وقد يكون هناك
سبب يجعلك ترى أن الدماغ
البشري ليس مهيئًا للتعرف على هذا النوع من
التهديد الوجودي المستقبلي الذي يتمتع به
البشر في رد الفعل تجاه الخطر المباشر ،
إنه استجابة فسيولوجية تسمى
القتال أو  -الطيران
حتى نتباطأ عندما تطير كرة بيسبول على
رأسنا أو نركض عندما يطاردنا كلب ولكن
عندما يتم توصيل الخيط
تدريجيًا بمرور الوقت مثل علامات التحذير
من تغير المناخ ، فإن أدمغتنا
تواجه صعوبة في استيعاب المدى
الكامل للخطر  كما أنه من الأسهل أيضًا
تجاهل المشكلة بدلاً من تقديم
تضحيات ، فمن المحتمل أن يكون نفس السبب
الذي نكافح فيه لإنقاذ التقاعد أو
التمرين  إنقاص وزنك ، فإن التضحيات
التي قد نقدمها اليوم في مكافحة
تغير المناخ قد لا تؤتي ثمارها إلا بعد
مرور سنوات ، وفي هذه الحالة
ربما لا حتى في حياتنا ،
يعتقد بعض الخبراء أن جزءًا من الحل
قد يكون في كيفية حديثنا عن تغير
المناخ  بدلاً من البدء
برأسك بكل حقائق البيانات الموجودة في رأسنا
للبدء من القلب ، هناك الكثير
من الأدلة على أن التعاطف يحفزنا
، اكتشف الباحثون أن الناس
أكثر عرضة للتصرف عندما يسمعون
نداءً عاطفيًا بدلاً من الحقائق أو البيانات فقط
تبين أن الأمل يمكن في الواقع أن يقلل من
القلق في الدماغ ، مما يجعلنا أكثر
انفتاحًا على الحلول الممكنة ، وإيجاد طرق
لربط هذه المشكلة العالمية الضخمة
بالمستوى المحلي أمر مهم أيضًا ،
فعلى سبيل المثال ، قد يتصل مزارع في كاليفورنيا
بقضايا الجفاف المتفاقمة أكثر
مما هو أو هي.  نود أن نسمع عن
ذوبان الأنهار الجليدية في جرينلاند ، لذا
فإليك الخلاصة ،
واحدة من أقوى غرائزنا هي
البقاء على قيد الحياة لدى البشر دافع فطري
نحو الحفاظ على الذات ، لذا إذا أردنا
أن يهتم السكان ويتعاونون بشأن
تغير المناخ ، نحتاج إلى تذكير الناس
بأن هناك حلولًا ستنجح
[موسيقى]